well i promised we'd review this one
soon but uh soon can have many
definitions
seeing as how my pal diego and i already
covered every alien game ever and every
avp game might as well get this one too
so without further ado
uh i know you're mostly used to hearing
me talk about comic book stuff and lord
knows the comments will all be about the
inevitable moon night video but let me
have something for me once in a while
huh if you're still dying for some comic
book content then why not check out
today's sponsor
special thanks to today's sponsor batman
unburied batman unburied is an all new
audio series streaming exclusively on
spotify the show skews more towards
suspense mystery and horror genres
appealing to batman fans and non-batman
fans alike batman unburied is a mature
and elevated story that grapples with
questions of identity morality and life
itself a fresh take on the timeless hero
this will be the first time audiences
will meet this batman in a 10 episode
fictional podcast series it's a show
that hopes to get people interested in
the world of audio storytelling and show
it's just as powerful as film and gaming
and while it features plenty of classic
villains this is an original version of
batman outside of the comics and movies
so you never know what can happen in the
story batman otherwise known as bruce
wayne an individual known throughout the
world as an arbitrator of justice a
billionaire playboy but genius
businessman and inventor who protects
the citizens of gotham as a mass
crusader but in batman and buried when
we first meet bruce we'll also see a
different side of him an ordinary
citizen as we work to unravel the
mystery of why bruce is so seemingly
different from the bruce wayne we all
know so too will our cape vigilante be
forced to solve how to save the citizens
of gotham from peril i'm interested in
the serious themes of whether or not
bruce wayne himself is just another mask
for the character and how much of
himself he puts on display when he's not
in costume plus i think an audio only
format worked really well for the
mystery detective side of batman like
the old radio plays about dc heroes back
in the day
it's cool to hear professional voice
actors really giving it their all and
just letting the words and the script
speak for itself
be sure to check it out on spotify for
free and vote for the poll in the
description now back to the video aliens
fire team
elite is part of the title ii i guess is
another in the long list of multiplayer
games based on 80s horror franchises we
don't get shoddy single-player movie
tie-in games anymore now these ips are
reserved for something like this or an
asymmetric multiplayer team-based game
where an iconic monster is clobbering a
team of survivors i guess between friday
the 13th predator hunting grounds dead
by daylight and evil dead
it's nice that this game is more about
playing offensively and has some
semblance of a plot in multiple levels i
compare this less to the rest of these
games and more like
left 4 dead i suppose kind of reminds me
of operation raccoon city 2 now that i
think about it but at least this is so
divorced from the lore of the movies
that it can't make any silly retcons
that damage the timeline yeah man leon
was totally being chased by these guys
before he got to the police station you
just played three different games that
didn't show that but this is the real
one
fire team is set 50 years after aliens
two and three so they can't do nothing
dumb the plot is about a spaceship full
of marines following a distress signal
to yet another of infinite planets in
this series called lv and then a random
set of numbers only to discover that the
weyland yutani scientists there were
studying alien eggs that eventually
broke containment
for the billionth time that's all of the
all of these have the same plot a rogue
ai called cynthia
is trying to deploy one of the engineer
ships from prometheus in the first movie
to eradicate earth with that black goo
which is apparently called the pathogen
i always felt like people were really
drastically overthinking how this
pathogen stuff works when the prometheus
movie came out
it doesn't have a complex set of rules i
just figured it was unstable in mutated
dna into all kinds of random stuff like
the mutagen from ninja turtles
just pretend it's glowing and green and
it's a lot simpler to wrap your head
around i guess maybe kind of sort of
after enough random mutations they
accidentally make the aliens
and on one of these ships the aliens
were a thing like a bajillion years ago
and laid a bunch of eggs in the cellar
while this blade runner goofball david 8
decided he wanted to make some aliens of
his own after he figured out that they
were a potential byproduct so he isn't
directly responsible for creating the
xenomorphs in general he just made a
couple of them that were out there after
he saw the other ones but it's going to
be forever unclear since that trilogy
got cancelled there's a lot of
unanswered questions and this is all
just my head cannons i guess i know none
of this is relevant to the game but i
[ __ ] love talking about aliens and i
don't get an excuse often enough to do
it but uh yeah i like that this game has
a fair amount of stuff from prometheus
and covenant reflected in its levels and
enemy designs
all these engineer ruins and statues are
a cool setting and i like that you can
even fight those animalistic mutant guys
from the movie that resembled a
xenomorph in the early concept art not
sure why they have uh
head crabs from half-life here i feel
like those were
already pretty derivative of face
huggers so you could have just used
those but maybe it was too hard to make
sense of how you wouldn't die the second
more than three of those entered the
room
they're pretty much canonically a
one-hit kill
other games just tried to scale back the
amount of them or let you try to wrestle
them away before they fully grabbed you
but
those all had the benefit of being first
person so doing that same type of
encounter in third person would have
been tricky it's not impossible just
would have been like awkward oh wait
those are here too just later in the
game i guess joke's on me for writing
the script as i was playing instead of
after as for actual aliens this game is
chock full of
the ones from alien 3 that look more
like dogs and are tiny
well tiny in some shots and big in
others these guys make up the vast
majority of the enemies in the game with
the more traditional big chap style
alien showing up is like a special enemy
type that's much bigger and stronger in
theory i think that's a good way to
handle it because it reminds you that
the standard alien is hard to kill and a
mean bastard that's like massive and
shouldn't be treated like fodder
but this also raises the question of why
does this colony have so many dogs and
or oxes there must have been a whole ass
farm or a zoo around or something
because remember every individual alien
had to have gestated in some equivalent
creature depending on what type it is
so this paints the picture that there
were like 99 dogs to every one human in
this colony and the ratio is really
confusing
were they using them on giant hamster
wheels to power the spaceship's
hyperdrive
it's a little baffling on top of that
you have a few special xenophenotypes
like crushers praetorians and spitters
the spitters hang back and use range
attacks while the crushers run at you
like everything else
the majority of the enemies tend to
fight more or less the same way which is
just charging at you blindly the nuance
of these different enemy types tends to
get lost in the chaos because there's
just
so many of them swarming you and in the
heat of the moment most of them look the
same so you really can't tell what's
that special about each shoot first and
observe characteristics never
in a weird way i feel like aliens
colonial marines had this more nailed
down because the aliens did have a more
tactical variety in that game some of
them would charge you sure but others
were more stealthy and tricky to find
and the really big aggro ones were
easily identifiable in a crowd the
drawback was that the shooting in that
game was miserable and not fun
so both of these feel close but not
quite there's some kind of middle ground
to be found here and while it was
terribly handled colonial marines had
the teensiest bit more storytelling this
game's story is conveyed not through cut
scenes but through static npcs with no
facial animation dryly reciting blocks
of expositional text desire to know more
does not intensify i find myself so
checked out of these conversations
because they're so detached and clinical
that i don't really want to spend more
time listening to them
after a while i started skipping through
them as fast as i could to get back to
the bug hunt you really know that
information was relevant it's just like
flavor text telling you okay
you know here's where you're gonna be
shooting at monsters for the next hour
i'm not sure why it only allows three
players instead of four that seems a
little arbitrary but maybe it was a
balancing thing or they decided four big
muscular space marines would start to
make these hallways feel a little too
cramped diego poppin let's say something
while alien's fire team remains mainly
as a linear wave based shooter with
simple objectives it still manages to
sprinkle in some modern video game
design choices that of the live service
games variety now before you raise your
pitch forks and torches there's nothing
offensive here the game has a road map
broken up into seasons each introducing
new content like weapons classes and
game modes at no additional cost you'll
also find challenges to complete for
extra experience points and currency
that you can use to buy cosmetics and
weapon upgrades gameplay modifiers can
spice things up a bit by giving enemies
things like increased damage or you can
alleviate the experience for yourself
with buffs
this is a great way to keep things fresh
and interesting i don't agree that video
games always need to fight that uphill
battle of having to stay relevant with
the steady flow of content for months
after the game's release i prefer a
tight and complete package out of the
gates with a memorable storyline and
engaging gameplay mechanics but alien's
fire team manages to keep these live
service-esque elements fairly tame
thanks to his decision to not nickel and
dime the player any chance they get i
don't love how the game pushes its
progression system at the end of every
session whether it be by completing a
level or dying you'll gain an amount of
experience points depending on your
performance every time you level up
you'll unlock more slots in your skills
loadout allowing you to equip more perks
that's all well and good we've seen
things like this thousands of times
before but the game pushes you to replay
levels by throwing in a drastic
difficulty spike at the end of every
level these instances are accentuated by
the fact that ninety percent of the
level is pretty much smooth sailing
but then the game kicks you into balls
and says i guess you're not quite ready
for this big guy better rack up some
more tickets and turn them in at the
price counter this gets tedious when
levels don't offer checkpoints and
you're forced to start over from the
very beginning if the game at least
gradually ramped up the difficulty
throughout the level it wouldn't be as
frustrating you'd hit a tough patch
maybe halfway or two-thirds into a level
incentivizing the player to do a bit of
grinding in order to progress that'd be
fair but the game teasing you with the
exit gates and throwing the entire world
at you and then some pulling you all the
way back to the starting point is really
demoralizing
thankfully the game offers a casual
difficulty setting for those that just
want to see the game through with
minimal frustrations but even on that
setting the difficulty spike is still
noticeable it's a universal constant
that all of these games end up inserting
white armored military androids or
soldiers or both as an enemy type to get
some gun battles in there
at least it's cool to see the working
joes again so it's a little bit of alien
isolation rep
but those were more menacing when they
were walking at you instead of sprinting
the shooting gameplay feels
serviceable if a little generic
it's easy to wrap your head around and
nothing about it really stands out is
especially unique but
it gets the job done
i really wanted to like this game
especially because it's made by such a
small team but the more i played it the
more depressed and nostalgic i felt for
alien isolation a shooting focused
multiplayer game is great for capturing
the hectic action movie feel of aliens
but i'm a die-hard survival horror guy
and i find myself longing for another
isolated terror focused experience where
it's just you in a creepy dark corridor
afraid to turn the next corner in case
two sets of teeth in one face ventilate
your forehead i feel like alien
isolation got a raw deal and i wish that
it spawned its own franchise of games to
compete with resident evil and evil then
and whatever evil games are out there
now it seems like this game is just
competing with its own limited budget
feels
like an indie game
like a really really impressive indie
game
but still just
cheap for an incredibly small staff this
is a decently made game but i wish the
ip wasn't in such a horrid state that
this is the best we can do like you
could tell there wasn't much money
thrown into this in fact it almost
reminds me of all the aliens themed rail
shooters just allowing you to walk and i
i feel like maybe i would have enjoyed
this more if it was just another one of
those in an ideal world this in the
isolation series would both be running
concurrently with a triple a installment
every few years and fans of both the
action and horror sides of the series
would get something that was kind of
tailor made for them
but we don't live in that universe so i
guess i should just be glad to get at
least this much
this game's not bad but it's not exactly
what i look for in alien-based games
it's just something to keep your hands
busy but it's not very engaging and
ultimately felt a little lifeless and
dull to me when playing it for longer
than a few minutes at a time if anything
aliens fire team is one of those turning
your brain off video games where you
just point and shoot your gun at the
waves of slimy monsters as you and your
friends hang out on discord and discuss
theories as to whether a facehugger
would be able to properly gestate a
person if it attached itself to
someone's butt
[Music]
[Music]
you